be alert and be prepared that is the
message from the flood control district
as flash flood season gets underway
christian casar is in studio with some
safety measures directly from the county
well brian today we got an update on a
multi-billion dollar project but the
question is it enough
we're modeling mother nature here and
that we're designing everything for that
one percent chance storm a multi-decade
project to protect the valley from
extreme weather is almost complete
according to the regional flood control
district
one of the newest sites is the 26
million dollar vanderburgh north
detention basin in north las vegas we're
up to 677 miles of channels and storm
drains and 104 detention basins have
been completed to protect this community
from flooding as flash flood season
rolls in from july to august north las
vegas mayor john lee says structures
like these are crucial to the
neighborhood and to the valley's growth
right across the street right there
there's 135 acres that are going to be
in in development in the next six months
henderson mayor deborah march reminding
all southern nevada residents to be
aware of how dangerous and unexpected
mother nature can be remember water
always wins
as flood water can travel up to 30 miles
an hour when it gets going 75 percent of
the master plan is complete that area is
in blue the red are those that are
pending projects stephen parish with the
regional flood control district says
they include the system along charleston
between maryland parkway and flamingo
charleston has been torn up for a few
months now and it's really affecting
businesses and
traffic through that area but it's
important that we get this structure
built
well the flood control district's plan
stems from the 1999 storm which caused
severe damage specifically near the
flamingo wash now when the next major
storm comes the system they say will be
ready christian casa is live local now